how's everyone doing today this is Steve
want rope with Collider and I am here
with writer director Steven Knight for
serenity how are you today so I'm very
good thank you
I thank you so much for coming in studio
as I was saying off-camera I think it's
been about three or four years since we
last spoke
yeah um so have you been doing I've been
very busy I've been doing a lot of stuff
and I think we'd spoke about to be
before yeah but there's been lots of
things going on since then
yeah I want to jump backwards yeah you
got into the industry a long time ago
but it feels like the last for me just
looking at your career it feels like the
last ten years have been on fast-forward
just you working a lot in on a lot of
cool projects
does it feel like that to you yeah I
mean it's a mixture of things there's
been a lot of stuff that I've written
recently but also a couple of times it's
a bit like fishing where you're I
ascription you cast a and you leave it
there and then ten years later somebody
comes along and makes it so it's the
same with the coming up there's a couple
of scripts I've written quite a while
ago that are being picked up and I
getting made and you know television has
happened and I love it and so I'm doing
quite a lot of TV as well I have a a
bunch of things to jump into but I want
to start with what would you love to
guest write and direct that you've seen
on television the issue that is I don't
really watch a lot of other TV I sort of
pretend it's deliberate so that it
doesn't affect what I do but to be
honest a lot of the stuff I'm watching
on TVs Peppa Pig
it's paw Patrol it's a lot kids stuff
right because the television is sort of
run by the kids that makes some sense
imagine I could guest write and direct
paw patrol craft this works you get fur
I can only imagine your version of that
show quite interesting you know so let
me I have a million of things but I want
to jump into why I get to talk to you
today talk a little bit about how this
where did this gripped come from in
terms of was this something that you've
been developing for a while or was this
like the idea came out of left field and
you're like I want to make this yeah it
I don't know where our ideas come from
and it's very difficult to sort of go
back I suppose the gestation of this was
a long time ago maybe seven years ago I
was I like to go fishing and I was in
Santa Lucia and I went on a tuna boat
fishing and the person who ran the boat
was really nice and good to you and and
gave you beer and you know was you're a
tourist and you're paying him so he was
really great until a fish bit and then
you didn't exist he was obsessed
obsessed with catching fish and I just
really liked this sort of this person
living in paradise with a beautiful life
has just couldn't relax he couldn't stop
he was driven to catch a fish so I
wanted to sort of recreate someone like
that in a situation like that but also I
was interested in the possibility of
writing a perfectly serviceable movie
with a script with a plot with
characters that work and then in a way
that are really my ambition was to make
it so that no one's expecting that you
pull the rug and you change it so that
was those two things came together and I
thought it would be great to do what
feels like a very simple straightforward
triangle if you like in terms of
characters and then make it something
totally other than that I I say congrats
to that because as I was watching I
something was gonna you know you're
building there's something going on here
but I could not figure it out until you
started giving more clues yeah in the
third act which is you know as someone
who's seen like about thousands of the
movies it's it's rare dude good well
that was the plan that was the ambition
I definitely ought to talk about the
casting process this is the first time
and and Matthew have worked together I
think since interstellar yeah so talk a
little bit out who came on the project
first and was one of these things where
one of them is texting the other being
like hey I'd say I think that did happen
I mean it's always mysterious to me how
scripts reach people I think it's yeah
you know CAA has its network and all of
that but that there are other what
mysterious ways where you will just get
contacted by someone sometimes directly
who happens to have read
script and that's what happened in this
case and I think it was Matthew who
responded first and it's always great
when you get someone like Matthew
McConaughey to engage and once we had
him we pretty much got first choices for
all gun and was first choice and you
know when those dominoes start to fall
it's always very satisfying has it
changed a little bit because you've been
writing some I mean after taboo you've
been writing so much stuff and been
getting really good actors so I guess my
question is when did the script get
finished let's start with that when did
you finish the script I think it was
probably about nine months before we
started shooting maybe a bit more maybe
twelve months because we spent some time
trying to find the location while I was
finishing off the script and we tried
different places we tried Dominican
Republic and I tried to make it work in
Bermuda but then finally we realized
that we got lucky with Mauritius so it
was about probably just over a year
before we started shooting so the
process on this was quite quick well my
question is so you finished the script
at that time is Matthew involved or is
it one of these things where you're
finishing the script and then you're
gonna push it out into the well yeah I
mean I don't tend to let it out until
it's done
until it's finished so once it was
finished it got out quite quickly and
you know responses came in quite quickly
as well when you so you finish the
script unit you are financing in place
at that moment or yeah I mean this was
what you know sometimes making a film is
really difficult sometimes it's
impossible and sometimes it just happens
somehow with doors opening and this was
one of those occasions where I'd done
two films with I am global which were
hummingbird and Locke and I just it just
seemed to be like we had a system going
and I showed them the scripts and they
said yeah we'll do it and then we got
Matthew and and then it you know that
all of the all of the procedures seemed
to happen quite effortlessly after that
sure you it's funny you mentioned that
about the script and getting into
Matthews hands
I've spoken to some other filmmakers
who I think drew Pierce with Hotel
Artemis he doesn't understand how Jodie
Foster got the script it's because he
hadn't released it yeah and somehow and
she called him and said I want to you
know do this yeah he's like how do you
even have this exactly and I don't know
what that system is around it's great
I'm glad it happens but it does seem to
be that there is not this sort of a fish
there is an official system where you
you know you say I'm offering this to an
especially an actor of a profile of
someone like Matthew you know he
wouldn't offer it to more than one actor
if one of them was Matthew McConaughey
but in this case it just seemed to find
its way into his hands sure so you you
finished the movie you shoot you finish
the movie you're in the editing room
which is ultimately the final rewrite
yeah what did you learn from friends and
family screenings or any test screenings
that impacted the finished film it was
the I think that's the major thing I
learned was not to underestimate an
audience in other words they're on to
you very quickly if you give any sort of
clues I mean it says you were saying
about tipping your hand if you give
small clues people are very literate in
movies and they will start to guess what
this what the twist is and I think it's
it's the same with any process like that
you have to take with a pinch of salt
the responses of people because in the
end you know you do a test screening for
members of the public and they'll fill
in their cards and all that but I think
in the end you have to make the film you
want to make and you can you can chase
your tail for so long you know trying to
change stuff but I think the main thing
I learned from those screenings was if
you are too generous with the clues as
to what's really going on people will
find out so did you have more clues in
the first act yeah I mean we had various
versions I mean you know in a way I sort
of wanted there to be no clues as well
but people I think feel a bit cheated
when there happened so you have to sort
of set things up I always think that in
filmmaking there is a tradition of
setting up a surprise you know you
prepare people for a surprise which in
my mind makes it not a surprise
so with this I wanted to keep it as
clean as possible to keep it as that is
what the film you're watching is just
that until you spring the truck yeah I
was gonna say that I for me planting a
few seeds is important yeah but not but
not germinating those seeds if you will
exactly and I mean I like the idea that
people know there's something going on
because what I've tried to do is make
the dialogue just a little bit large
just a little bit new Irish just a bit
not real just so that people would guess
that this wasn't quite the reality
they're expecting when you're working on
the script though you have to be like
okay I'm hoping I'm gonna get some
actors but having Jason Clarke Anne
Hathaway Matthew McConaughey and a
number of other people that are you know
strong supporting roles
you know Diane Lane Jeremy strong the
early yeah
when when did you realize oh [ __ ] I this
really came together yeah and again it's
it's one of those mysterious things
about the way films happen is that
sometimes you can labor and work and you
know go after people and try and put it
together than the finance then falls
apart and then when you get the fireman
the actor is is busy I mean all the
familiar things everybody knows but
sometimes things just happen quickly and
easily and that was this was one of
those occasions and I think not because
of any sort of ability on my part it's
just sometimes you get lucky did you
have a much longer first cut with a lot
of deleted scenes or was it yeah I mean
as ever you know that is about what you
get rid of and we had quite a bit of
stuff that didn't make it in it's really
important to have that amount of stuff
so that you know you can cut stuff up
you know I'd love one day to roast good
well I suppose Locke was like this but
one day write a script where everything
you're right ends up on the screen I
guess that would be sort of quite a
satisfying process but it's never really
works out another did you have like 20
minutes of deleted scenes or is it just
a little bit you know it's probably
about 15 so what what's like kind of
some of the stuff that you cut out was
it like repetitive dialogue ER and for
me I think I think the only way to in my
opinion with the Edit
it's rather than go into a scene and
chip away at it I think it's best to
leave the scene alone let it breathe but
then if you're going to cut a whole
scene so you know there were whole
characters that were taken out not
because of anything that to do the
character but to do with pacing and to
do with you know what that character is
revealing so yeah I mean we're you know
we took my view is take a whole lump
rather than take a little bit salt I'm
what is it like say so you cut remove a
character what is it like calling that
actor and saying hey you did great but
it's just not gonna make the movie I
wouldn't know because I'm a coward you
know I think that the great thing about
actors they know the business they know
it's tough and I think you know everyone
knows that things are gonna change in
the Edit so you know that's life that's
the way it is I think do you when
something like that happens and it's say
an actor that's not very well known but
they had some key scenes with Matthew
McConaughey is it something where you're
willing to maybe let them have some of
that's for their real or it's once it's
cut I mean they can have all of it for
their I mean if someone wants something
to help them with their career I
wouldn't stand in the way of that one
bit you know but you know so be it with
a writer you're right Stephanie gets
rejected sometimes so that's just that's
the business really what was the scene
and I don't want to do spoilers but was
there a scene that you repeatedly went
back to because every time I speak to
directors they talk about how there's
always a scene or two that you are
struggling with the entire edit and what
was that for you I suppose a couple of
scenes near to the I mean the the scene
I'm most pleased with is the scene on
the beach with Matthew and Jeremy and
that I went back to so many times
because there's certain reveals in there
that either you do reveal or you don't
it was very important to me to get that
right because I'm trying to make
something that's about an existentialist
sort of treatment of what a film can be
so that in the end ultimately the
questions Matthew is asking and the
discussion he has with Jeremy on the
beaches about
the nature of existence which I don't
care if it sounds portentous or
pretentious what's the point of doing
things if you're not going to explore
something like that and so it is about
you know the nature of reality so I went
back to that many times but I think that
there's also an issue with when you when
you're putting the film together is that
the scenes that you love the most or
often for some reason attract the most
attention in terms of cutting look
sometimes people always seem to go for
the scene that you love most and try to
cut it because of in my opinion a scene
that doesn't no work a scene that
doesn't move the plot along which is
often considered to be superfluous the
way I say is it must be there for a
reason other than plot so it's probably
good I'm yeah it's so it's so
interesting to talk to so many directors
and you mention how you might remove a
whole scene and I'll talk to other
directors will be like that we just
picked away at it you know I mean
everybody's different and God you know
everybody's right in their own way and
wrong as well and I think it's a
question of for me you know when I'm
writing it I hope I'm going through the
editing process there and then on the
page so that in terms of dialogue I
always feel that I've got that I've got
the dialogue right that's how it should
be
and so therefore moving that around is
difficult whereas if you say okay this
scene isn't earning its place then you
can just take it out with a movie like
this where there's more going on than
what you see how have you been
describing it to friends the film it's
difficult because it's I hope it's a
thriller I don't really like the word
noirish but I hope it's a thriller that
appeals to people who like thrillers and
people do like fishing yeah I saw
someone called a sexy noir sexy sexy
fishing noir sure let the like on a
rephrase it sexy fishing noir exactly so
I want to jump on to a few other things
real quick I had no idea that you were
one of the creators of who wants to be
millionaire yes I'm very proud of it
many years ago myself and two of us I
was writing as well but I was working at
a production company that also did
gameshow so you could just walk up the
stairs and say I've got an idea and one
of them was it wants to be a millionaire
and that was fantastic
it is in a hundred and sixty countries
yeah that's just insane yeah I've heard
a statistic that said it's the most
watched TV program in history or
something it's it's crazy it's crazy I
don't want to uh I was gonna make a joke
but I mean you do okay so my question is
when it's cold in London and you need to
warm their house are you burning
hundred-dollar bills parents no a
hundred pounds I'm sorry yeah no I mean
it was very kind to me and all the other
people involved it was great but you
know I I write because I'm sort of
compelled to do it so I was I don't
think I will ever stop writing sure but
you are burning hundred pound notes to
get warm eco-friendly biomass so I loved
Eastern Promises and there was always
talk for a while about more in that
story it's coming is it it's written and
I've heard that yeah but is it really
coming well funnily enough as of right
now you know as I say it is like fishing
where you leave it out there and it's
been out there for a while and it went
through permutations in the sense of you
know how do you follow
Vico so we've been through that when
we've moved on and now we're in a
position where I will say watch this
space but we're close to getting into
production really yeah and is this gonna
be so it's not with Vigo though no and
it's a I mean I you never know and who
do you have a director yes I can't
really talk about this yet but yes I
don't want you in trouble no we do have
a director and when we are at to a
couple of really good actors I
completely get it so you do you think
this could be actually be filming this
year
yes so you were financing and things
it's just question of lockdown exactly I
got it um that's awesome is it the same
script that you wrote a while ago yeah I
mean I was it's changed a bit and it
changed quite recently as a result of
events in the world because of the
topicality of the Russian thing
and so yeah I've adapted it to reflect
recent events I don't want to get you in
any more trouble but I cannot wait
jumping into taboo so I watched the
first season we talked a long time ago
and when I saw Tom Hardy last I said oh
so where's the second season get off
your ass and sorry where is the second
season
it's almost completed in terms of the
script we had to cut the delays because
of other commitments but we are hoping
to start shooting end of this year of
the start next ok so it's definitely
coming yes it's and how does is there a
time jump from the first season is it
could I believe it if I'm not mistaken
it was designed as a three season show
it still will be I mean I you know if I
if we all stick with it and we all want
to keep doing it would be through that's
that's my plan because I've got a
geographical sort of route for the thing
to take and it's basically a journey
West and so yeah I mean I I have a
destination in mind which is always nice
to have if you're you know if you're
setting up on this is a big journey
which is what writing three eight hours
is it's good to know where you're
heading and so it's another eight hours
for season two yeah yeah I I'm I'm
saying awesome you have a great
relationship with Tom you've worked
together a number of times what is it
does he have compromising pictures of
you or do you have compromising pictures
of him it's really strange because I
think it works because we don't
socialize you know we do occasionally
but not very often
and I think that the relationship is
totally about the work and the great
thing about Tom is that's his passion is
the work there of the acting you know he
he's not a fan of celebrity but he just
loves to act and he loves the process
and the craft and for me to have him
occasionally available to do roles that
you've written is is wonderful because
you know you know you can trust someone
to to really deliver what you do and I
mean Locke and and taboo were sort of
came about because of each other where I
was invited to meet Tom to talk about
writing this thing to be and I was
developing Locke and Tom was parking his
car and I spoke to his manager and said
that do you mind if I mention this
project he said no so we did a deal
where he would do Locke if I did to me
that's so funny you guys might also do a
Christmas Carol yet we are definitely
doing that I mean that is written it's
going to be 3-1 hours and it's largely
done finished in terms of the script
we're planning to shoot this year and
hopefully get it on the screen for
Christmas so is it so it's is this like
a BBC thing like who's at BBC plus an
American element which has not been
announced yet I understand and so what
role is Tom playing in this not gonna
reveal say no again don't want to get
Betty's going to be is going to be
pivotal in the whole thing got it is it
that's not a clue have you thought about
other casting and stuff yeah yeah I mean
we're out to a couple of people what I'm
trying to do and what I'm planning to do
is adapt five Dickens know I mean
Christmas carols not really novel but
adapt Christmas Carol plus four novels
and do it over a period of let's say six
or seven years and have a repertory of
actors and I think we get the best
actors hopefully in the world to to take
part because the Dickens characters are
so great and just do like Copperfield
and Oliver Twist and great expectations
and do them in in a modern way I mean
that not really in a taboo way but it's
sort of like that
and well the thing about taboo is it's
real ready it is like you're stepping
back in time in terms of the dirt yeah
the mud yeah it's like you're there so
is that what you kind of the element you
want to add - yes I mean the idea is
that when Dickens was writing I mean he
would have been a TV returning series
writer I think because that's how he
worked and he when he wrote his novels
he did it in installments and release
them in magazines so that people were
that there were cliffhangers and people
were waiting for the next episode and as
far as he could according to the sort of
fashions of the time he did deal with
the darker side of London and poverty
and you know things that were really
going on he couldn't really go into the
detail in the way that we can so what
I'm trying to do is things that are past
possibly implied in Dickens we can
actually Express I like this it'll be
great I think it's really good I mean I
think if we if we can by age novel eight
hours of good television with really
good actors it'll be something that you
can at the end of it you can say look I
did this system I got it so it's
basically each year so this year would
be Christmas Carol what what do you have
an order or a not set in stone or quite
fancy doing David Copperfield mix it's
so interactive would yet but Tom would
be in each one I think so yeah yeah of
course you know I mean you also
something I'm so excited for because I'm
a big fan of Francis Lawrence is this
new Apple shows a few people that are
involved and it sounds very high concept
and big if I'm not mistaken you wrote an
episode or are you how involved are you
I've written people written all about I
mean I create well yeah I created it and
really by the way eating my shoe right
now okay yeah it's a it's an idea I had
and I don't quite know where it came
from but I had an idea and wrote at the
first hour and then when I did a rewrite
I've wrote the first two hours because
it just sort of kept going and then we
offered it around and
Apple have taken it and that's very
exciting so we started shooting in I
think it was October and up in Vancouver
and it's going to be I mean I'm looking
buddy enough I'm looking at the cut of
the first two episodes tomorrow morning
and the rushes are amazing everybody's
very very excited I I'm very confident
with Francis he's what we call very
talented he's wonderful and calm and
gets things done and actors love him and
he's very you know inspired and creative
he's fantastic the thing about
television right now is that as someone
who does this for a living I cannot keep
up with the abundance of television and
I can't keep up with great television
there's so many great shows this is
gonna be Apple's big first push into the
the medium if you will what do you think
it is about the show that can you know
elevate it beyond you know what I mean
when people are talking yeah yeah well I
mean the concept is quite far out you
know and and I think what I've tried to
do is make it about more than the
component parts so it's sort of I hope
it's sort of it's mythological and also
I hope it's about the way things are now
and the way people are and bigger issues
other than you know just the plot and
the story and the thrill of the ride but
that there is something there that will
be more enduring I think the obviously a
lot of the network's are spending a lot
of money
Netflix whoever it is on making
television look amazing how is Apple as
a partner as a as the producer and are
they sort of going big if you will yeah
again a lot of this is not announced but
yeah there were good reasons why we
wanted to do then which are to do with
what's on the screen and off is okay I'm
very okay I'm just trying to think if if
there could be tie-ins with certain
Apple products or oh it's not so much I
mean I just I just like I liked the the
ethos that was presented I mean I don't
know
that the rest of Apple as a there's a
corporation but the people who are
making the television I've sensed some
genuine desire to do really good stuff
yeah I as I said the other thing though
is it's gonna be their first show so you
know if not the first in the second but
it's yeah I mean I think that that
decision hasn't been made but yeah we
hope we'll be there do you I looked at
are you doing Rio
what were my talking about this no no I
wrote I wrote that's good quite a while
ago as well and yet we are close to
going into production thing so basically
this year is another record year for you
yeah I mean I'd it's strange how all
these things come together but it there
are a few things coming together all at
the same time which is great because
they're written so I can sort of sit
back and let the other people do the
work and then there will be a few
rewrites I suppose but yeah you know
it's shaping up to be quite busy when
you're writing a script for example with
serenity or Rio or anything else how
long does it typically take you and are
you showing early drafts to people or do
you like do eight drafts and then start
showing it no I don't show anybody
anything until it's till it's really
unless there's a really good reason and
I can't think of well so what I tend to
do is rather than write the whole thing
and then go back to the beginning and do
a whole drop I tend to keep I always
start that whenever I sit down to write
I start at the beginning so I go through
everything that's already written and
change it and change it and change it as
I'm going along and then I don't tend to
have a plan when I start sometimes not
even what it's about I tend to sort of
sit there and start and then almost see
what I've written you know I mean it and
go through and then look at it and think
well what's that about you know how did
that Joe and sometimes things happen on
the page that completely contradict
stuff you've done before and you have to
sort of give authority to what came last
so you have to reverse engineer the
whole thing so it's a very odd process I
think and I tried
to make it to logical and conscious if
possible it's so interesting to so many
writers I speak to have a very detailed
treatment I didn't do that I couldn't I
think oh it's not as if I'm saying this
is the best way of doing it because it's
not because it's quite inefficient but
for me I try to it it sort of thought
about and for me it's more like you know
everybody dreams you could be fall
asleep and you have a dream and in that
dream it's very weird and bonkers and
all sorts of strange things happen but
the characters are true and the dialogue
is really good and everybody does it you
know I mean if you think about your
dream it's sometimes a character based
on someone you know steps into the dream
and you have a conversation there must
be a part of everybody's mind that is
capable of creating fiction from what is
known you know the facts around them so
I try if I can to get when I'm writing
to sort of allow myself into that
situation where it's almost as if it's a
dreams are you writing so with serenity
how long did the project actually take
to write probably six weeks oh that's
not there I mean yeah I mean it's quite
I think if it's good it's quick if it's
slow there's a reason and it's probably
not so good so if something's really
stuttering out and taking ages it's
probably not it's probably not right
what is the fastest script that you've
written and which is the one that took
you the longest oh boy if you remember I
can't remember that is that sometimes
you start and then you're on something
else and then you're back on something
but I would say quickest would be luck I
think because that just came almost as a
single event something and some of the
others have taken a long time when my
last things for you the right now the
theatrical business has kind of shifted
a little bit where it's more like event
pictures yes and the superhero genre has
turned into the thing that's a normal
thing yeah it's just massively popular
yeah does the superhero genre at all
interest you and have you had people
asking you to work on it because it
seems like that's the thing that is
really yeah
I mean I've been asked to do stuff I'm
not against it I don't think you know
it's it there's anything wrong with it I
think it's a problem if it that's all
that's of all that's on offer and I
think the you know the structure of the
business being what it is where you have
to fill so many big theatres that you
know you tend to get restricted in what
you can do it's not something that I
would sit down and choose to do and you
know but obviously World War Z - and all
that I've worked on and in a sense
curling the spider's web as well you
know that they are genre films and I'm
more than happy to do them because it's
writing and it's in and the money's good
and and it's good fun to do but I just
hope that I think the thing that needs
to be reformed is theatres is the way
that people meet a film you know that
they have to go to a theatre in the way
in a very conventional way and sit down
with loads of other people mocked it's
because there's got to be another way of
getting smaller budget perhaps more
relevant films about real reality not
than my films about reality but you know
the smaller films getting them out there
and getting them to people because I
think the job of a writer and the
director is really simple you've got to
get people in a room turn off the lights
and getting to look at the screen for 90
minutes or two hours however you can do
that just do it any way you want and I
worry that the more there are rules and
regulations that are imposed on
filmmakers because of the financial
constraints the less creativity they'll
be I I've said repeatedly that I think
the biggest issue is that theaters are
so structured with their with the rule
for example I firmly believe that a
movie that costs 10 million dollars and
a movie that costs two hundred million
dollars should not be the same ticket
price I just think there needs to be
different pricing and I also think that
where you sit in the theater if you're
in the first few rows should be cheaper
than you're in the prime middle of the
theater yeah there are things that can
be done to entice people to come in and
see small
movie yeah but they don't want to do it
it is a and I think that's wise
television is sort of prospered so much
is that a lot of people including myself
see creative freedom much more in
television sure I've taken so much of
your time and I haven't even talked
about a peaky blinders and a whole bunch
of other things but I'm gonna leave that
for next time
I will just say thank you so much for
coming in as a pleasure Congrats on this
thank you and I'm very curious of other
people what they're gonna think because
it is not everything it is not exactly
what you see no exactly you know on that
note thank you so much thank you and
we're out
you